who do people trust the most a
politician or a ghost
are we messed up in the head if we
believe less in the living than the dead
new research and boy do i love that new
research smell
finds that people believe in ghosts more
than they trust the government
it's tough
it's tough competition
considering how invisible kamala harris
is
i don't know
i don't know if i deserved applause on
that i but anyway a poll i'm taking it
a poll of nearly a thousand people in
the uk
also called the uk
found that 50 believe in the existence
of ghosts meanwhile just 20 said they
have faith in the government and even
fewer had faith in the power of
toothpaste
because it's england
just in case so what to make of this
what would this poll say if it were done
in the u.s it's hard to say since
democrats do so well with dead voters
[Applause]
not to mention the poltergeist currently
haunting the oval office
and years ago let's face it democrats
did ride around wearing white
sheets i'm getting a lot of applause
today i'm not used to this so basically
a random person on the street is more
than twice as likely to believe in
casper than kamala
by the way that same survey found that
only 12 percent said they believe in
magic
clearly they've never seen me in a pair
of leather chaps tyrus
talk about magic
[Applause]
but as for believing in ghosts more than
politics maybe it's not a bad thing
well
until you run into a ghost who happens
to be political
welcome back to ghost explosion i'm your
host terry phantasm we're here in the
incredibly well preserved living room of
notorious victorian era serial killer
oswald von chapstick this place is
crawling with paranormal activity
did you hear that show yourself spirit
oh well if it isn't another privileged
white male hosting a tv show you know
you're glorifying the victorian era a
time when women were second-class
citizens and coal-burning train travel
was destroying the ozone and factories
were abusing the rights of labor workers
and as for today the democrats are in
danger of losing their house majority in
the upcoming midterm elections cause you
know what's actually scary republicans
okay shut the cameras off and by the way
how is your hair outside the sheet
[Music]
i already know the answer to this
question cat but i'm going to ask you
anyway have you ever seen a ghost no
and that bumped you out i've tried i
know i try to conjure them up no i yes
because i really want something to
believe in yes exactly
okay
that's why i have a ouija board yeah i
was scared of the ouija board though yes
oh my three older sisters i knew they
moved that thing around but i didn't but
it still scared the hell out of me well
my mom told me if i ever played with it
there'd be devils in the house
she was right
you are the devil me right yeah
dude uh but having said that you don't
believe in ghosts you still believe in
ghosts more than you believe in god yeah
i i don't know for sure no ghosts i know
that i do not believe in the government
yes
tyrus
i don't believe in ghosts but i believe
my digestive system is haunted
okay um wow
i'm not i don't care how much they apply
i'm not doing this tonight
[Laughter]
[Applause]
culturally as you may know or may not
know i'm black we don't have time to
believe in ghosts we got to deal with
other
we have free-loading relatives we don't
need ghosts
staying in the damn house and we all
have them and no one wants to put up
with a haunted house because chances are
it's going to be a racist haunted house
that's true
every time i come home it's changing the
locks and it's like get out
[Laughter]
pay rent so i don't need that but we
don't have time for that
uh
digging is this this is a helpful survey
i think it is like you know it's it just
tells you how little trust people have
in government i i don't need a survey
because i can pose this question to
anybody hey you want to come over to my
parents house and hang around the room
my mama died in
or
would you rather come over to my house
and hang out with a politician who's
going to chew your ear off for two hours
and then pick your pocket and do nothing
for you they would always
yeah just dead mom
you know maybe a cold breeze blows
through you it smells like lavender she
wakes you up in the middle of the night
but you get something from it yeah
you'd be uh
you'd be a great
real estate agent
and over here uh over here
there's a lot of job titles that's true
but think about this you can come and go
and this is the dead mom room over here
yep
i tell everybody that who comes over you
know you're sitting it's i'm stealing
this from cat you're suddenly you know
you're sending the chair that mama died
in
i make a lot of friends that way all
right walter
what this study proves is that they're
running out of studies
[Laughter]
[Applause]
but since they did it it caused me to
think about the similarities between
ghosts and government right
uh like
government ghosts live in old houses the
white house yes um
like government they kind of keep you up
at night and then you wake up in a cold
sweat like that the irs causes you to do
like government ghosts are mostly white
[Applause]
but you know as i say i don't i don't
think that studies like this really
prove anything except that we're giving
too much money to our universities
[Applause]
here's an exit question if you will and
i'll post it to you cat when uh when a
ghost uh blows off another ghost
is that called
being human what
being human
please refrain please refrain
change the rephrase the question
ghost blows off another ghost takes the
blows off part out when it goes a ghost
with yours
is it called being human no it's just
called being a
[Applause]
can't take these people anywhere
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else